Hey youtubers it’s Charlie, thanks everyone
that submitted questions for the Walking Dead
Q&A this week.
Lots of stuff to talk about so we’ll get
to that first but I also have a few updates
at the end of the video.
There were also a few things Scott Gimple
and Greg Nicotero Confirmed after the episode,
first was that the guy in the flashbacks wasn’t
Negan, he was crazy tattoo man.
They’re doing something super secret with
Morgan.
And there will be at least one new villain
that will rival the Governor in his level
of evilness.
So careful for spoilers if you haven’t seen
the episode yet.
I’ll wait just a sec...okay, here we go.
Question 1 - Derp Muffin asks, do you think
Beth will reunite with the group?
Yes, I don’t think she’s going to die.
But it will probably be most of the season
before she sees them again.
I believe we won’t catch up with her till
the third episode.
But presumably there will be some exposition
explaining how she got there and who those
people are.
I don’t think they’re doing the exact
same thing as they did with Terminus.
I did follow all the news from when they were
filming this season.
So I don’t want to get into crazy spoilers.
But I can definitely say that other place
won’t be the same deal as Terminus.
They’re not just going to blow it up the
first time we see it.
I think Beth’s arc this season is going
to be the natural progression from those Daryl
field trip episodes in season 4.
She’s just slowly growing up and learning
how to deal on her own.
I think they’ll be drawing that out as much
as possible.
But Emily Kinney is still a series regular
as far as I know, so even though she won’t
be with the Survivors, we’ll still see a
lot of her.
Just in separate scenes.
Question 2 - Edward asks, do you think Morgan
will reunite with the group by the next episode
or are they going to drag it out?
No, Scott Gimple confirmed that there would
be more Morgan but that it will largely be
separate.
Kirkman and Gimple have both said that they
incorporated a lot more elements from the
comics this year.
That doesn’t mean they’re straight up
copying what happens in the comics, but if
you’ve read the comics, some people and
things will seem a lot more familiar.
I feel like that’s them gently suggesting
everyone start reading the comics.
Right now I’m behind, so if you’re not
reading the comics yet don’t feel bad.
I haven’t read All Out War yet.
I think Morgan will be just like the Beth
storyline, we’ll just see way less of him.
They’ve already said the group will head
back to a big city that we’ve already been
to which is Atlanta.
So it’s possible Morgan could also head
in that direction.
I don’t think he’ll be a regular on the
show as part of the group till next year though.
The actor that plays him says he loves coming
on, so even if he never becomes a series regular,
he’ll still keep coming back.
Question 3 - Jasmine asks, do you think Gareth
will die this season or turn good and join
the Survivors?
The actor that plays Gareth was promoted to
Series regular after the finale last year.
So he’s going to be in several if not most
of the episodes this season.
That doesn’t necessarily mean he’s going
to turn good or join the Survivors.
I’ve seen a lot of theories that he and
any other people left from Terminus would
turn into the Hunters from the comics.
They were already cannibals, the Hunters are
just much more mobile.
It’s possible Gareth and who ever is left
from there could just haunt Rick and the Survivors
all season.
Question 4 - Kaz asks, Where did Rick and
the Survivors go at the end after they reunited?
It seems like they headed in the opposite
direction from Terminus.
They run into Father Gabriel in the teaser
for episode 2 and it looked like they were
way off somewhere else.
I don’t know where his church is on the
map, but in the trail they’re seen approaching
it at night.
So it’s not going to be a simple “save
gabriel” then go back to his place and chill
thing.
All of the other trailer scenes inside the
church look like they’re from next week
too.
Father Gabriel in the comics is a really interesting
character, so I’m going to be interested
to see how much of that they include.
In case you don’t want to know anything
about him, just turn the volume down till
you see this tag go away.
Okay…
Right after the apocalpyse Gabriel hoarded
supplies in his church and refused to let
people in.
Very un-godly thing to do, he was afraid of
running low on food and water.
So he carries around the guilt of the people
who died because of his selfishness.
Okay spoilers over.
If you guys want I can talk more about him
in next week’s video.
Seth Gilliam is a great actor and gets them
one step closer to hiring every single actor
to ever appear on The Wire.
Question 5 - Daniel asks, Will the show make
sense if I just start watching right now in
season 5?
It will take you longer to develop connections
to the characters but you’ll still be able
to follow the story.
Even though it’s highly serialized, they
write episodes knowing there are people watching
for the first time and people may not have
read the comics.
So they add bits of exposition and moments
to explain what’s going on.
Question 6 - shihab asks, why would they bring
Sam back just to kill him off at the beginning
of the episode?
Big shout out to The Penguin.
They said they flew him in for one day just
so he could kneel at that trough and get killed.
He was the redshirt they used to crank up
the threat level.
Him and the guy right next to him.
They just wanted us to feel like they were
actually going to kill everyone in there.
Robin Lord Taylor for those who don’t know,
is The Penguin on Gotham.
That show just got picked up for a full 22
episodes.
It’s airs Monday nights and I do videos
for it every week.
It’s a lot of fun so you should check it
out.
Question 7 - horror geek asks, there are only
about 5 characters left from the original
pilot episode.
How long do you think they’ll all survive?
I’m starting to think that they’ll keep
them indefinitely.
I know there was all the playful Negan winks
to a certain comic book moment.
But I think the only time they kill off major
characters is when they sense the group gets
too comfortable.
The minute everyone is safe and happy is when
we should all start worrying.
I think that what we’ll see now is a rift
develope between Abraham’s group and the
Survivors over the Cure.
And that will create all the internal tension.
Gareth and whoever else shows up will be the
external tension.
There always has to be threats inside the
group and threats outside the group.
If things get too crazy with Abraham’s group
though, I think it would be a lot more likely
that Abraham or Eugene would die.
Abraham is the kind of guy who picks fights
and Eugene is Walker Bait without his protection.
Question 8 - HR Productions asks, do you think
Gareth is the only one who survived Terminus?
No, but I do think most of them died.
I think we’ll get an exact number in the
next two episodes.
If they don’t show up next week.
We also found out that the guy on the slab
here being cut up, was Gareth’s Brother
and Mary who got eaten by walkers was his
Mother.
Question 9 - Blacksmith Rage asks, do you
think Michonne will get her Katana Back?
I didn’t see Carol grab it, so I’m assuming
it’s still back at Terminus.
Michonne looks like she had it in the trailer
so it’s possible someone will circle back
and get it or Carol grabbed it and I just
missed it.
Question 10 - Angus asks, do you think this
season will be a lot less standing around
and talking like when they were on the farm
and at the prison?
We know they head to the church with Father
Gabriel, but I’m not sure how long they’ll
stay there.
They will be traveling for most of the season,
so it’s possible they’ll drift from stop
to stop while they head to Atlanta.
Gimple said we’d see familiar places and
a lot of new ones.
So they won’t be settling down wherever
they go.
Question 11 - Raul asks, do you think Carol
is a version of Andrea from the comics?
She was also a good sharpshooter and a bad
ass.
They do share a lot of similar qualities.
I don’t think they’ll have exactly the
same arc though.
I think Andrea in the comics is kind of divided
between Michonne and Carol right now.
Both those TV Characters share some parts
of Andrea’s story.
Question 12 - Purely Awesome asks, why do
you think they chose not to show Tyreese killing
that Terminus Guy, why didn’t he want Carol
to go in the Cabin?
There is a small chance that he did not kill
the dude and he just doesn’t want Carol
to find out.
I think Tyreese having a problem killing people
will work into the Gareth storyline and probably
cause some problems later on.
They’ll definitely address it again.
If you remember the Lizzie Mika storyline.
They offhandedly started that with the Rats
in Season 4 Episode 1.
So hopefully this won’t turn into a “look
at the flowers tyreese” situation.
Thanks so much everyone for submitting questions.
And congratulations to this week’s giveaway
winner, Oliver Yoshi.
You win the amazon gift card this week.
For those asking.
It’s a new giveaway every week.
And I’m also doing giveaways in my Doctor
Who and Game of Thrones videos.
Probably some other random giveaways too.
So the more different things you check out
the better your chances are of catching that
stuff.
Next week, shit goes down with Father Gabriel,
I’ll probably have a bonus video before
the episode airs too.
Right now click here for my Episode 1 WTF
video and click here to learn all about the
new walking dead spinoff show.
Thanks for watching, now let’s all high
five and I’ll see you tonight for gotham!